can hear you martin
[Music]
morning
absence damon could you give an update
do we have any absences to
informal um yes with you cheer we have
apologies from councillor dale
okay thank you moving straight on to
point number two declarations of
interest so i'd like members to
declare if they've got any additional
disclosable procurement interests other
than what is
already written on their submissions to
date
if not then i'll move swiftly on again
point three there's the
minutes from the last meeting so i'd
like to move that
the minute circulated this week is a
true reflection
of the minutes from the clay crosstown
board meeting held on the 18th of
september
it comes for renwick second that
thank you then we have to put that to
the record
and i can make a small change to the
agenda uh due to the
commercial sensitivity of the town
investment plan
if we move that to the end of the
meeting when we're not live streaming
so i'd move on to point five which is a
working group
structure so i'd hand over to carl apps
to give an update to you please
and thank you chair um i'm hidden behind
this somewhere even like here we go
so i'm here to see you away this meeting
is being recorded
okay so the first part is the working
group so as you're aware we
have had some groups working already
and that will continue once the town
investment plan
has been submitted and we move into the
the project proposal
uh development stage and business case
development and a big part of that work
is
around those obviously those areas have
been identified
um but what we're hoping for is that we
can get some
sponsors from the board to work with
these groups and then they'll come to
the board
meetings and then they will feedback as
to the progress of these individual
working groups and i sent this out
earlier in
the week and um we've had some
people put their hand up and ask if they
can be involved so
the town centre regeneration group which
is currently configured as the built
environment working group
and that's looking at the market street
bridge tree projects
uh infill housing biodiversity public
realm traffic management
kearney green industrial
pieces of work so we've asked for some
some
um people for that and council morley
and council and andrew
king have both put their names forward
and uh council rene was asked if she
would be able to also attend those
groups to support
the uh the delivery of that piece of
work
um also we've got the skills and
enterprise
board this is an established board and
um
it's already well attended from council
members but also from outside parties
and
uh richard morkum has asked if he could
be the um
the sponsor for that particular group
and so he'll feed back to the
the clay crosstown board as to the
progress
and the work that's happening with that
shelley park
um legend center and that that board
that working group has been in
established pre the um town investment
plan because that's a piece of work
that's been happening
probably since about january 2019 so
that's um
quite well progressed um compared to
some of the other pieces of work
and so there's an existing working group
and a couple of the board
members are already um on that group
so um it's been decided that that
working group will continue as it is
because it's it's well established and
working well and that lee hicken
will um respond to the board that's the
piece of work that's happening on there
because he
i believe he chairs the um clay cross oh
slightly shy park
center board and then we also have the
clay cross
creative and as you were that's the um
the group was in development at this
point and it's around
um youth initiatives active events
public art programs
and linking with the skills hub as well
and councillor barker
um would like to be the link from that
group
to this board and then we also have the
shadow youth board
at this point that's a board that's not
yet in development
but it's something that we're going to
do over the course of
um now and the town investment plan
coming back hopefully
to say that it's been agreed the heads
of terms so um
initially i was going to try and work
with the local um
younger people to try and pull that
together and potentially calling on
um colleagues from chesterfield college
and potentially the university
and to see that we can try and get a
spread of clay cross
um residents on that board
and the the aspiration is that the the
head chair of that board which will be a
youth
person and will be the person who then
attends this board
and does the um the link from that too
so at this point the the board doesn't
have a representative from that youth
chair because it doesn't obviously exist
but they will do and they will bring
that forward and we think that's an
important part of the engagement
uh plan for the the next stage of the
project development
and um i think it's essentially good
practice and to make sure those people
who are
sometimes disenfranchised from this
piece of work will be involved
so that name is to be confirmed but i'll
support them working with us
as i said colleagues from the college
university to
identify the right people
and then the last one is we've got the
low carbon energy type
work which has been um a golden thread i
suppose working through
the town investment plan and we feel it
is our unique selling point
and makes us sort of stand out and
the the person who's put the hand up for
that um is bob murdock
from worcester bosch um again
obviously an expert in energy and local
so
it'd be great if and bob can do that and
be that link between that group
which is in development and obviously we
need to sort of progress some of this
stuff and we've had
people from kaiden um say that they wish
to be involved in this group as well so
we
we've got some of the right people
around and involved
and then finally we've got the the rail
group um as you know we want a train
station as part of this ask is to sort
of
town investment plan we'll lay the
ground for
a rail station in clay cross hopefully
in the foreseeable future
and um lee rowley has agreed to
be the the link between that group and
this board and
lee as you're aware is very passionate
about rail and connectivity
and sustainable transport so and that's
that's a great fit for us i think
so and that's the working groups as
we've established
um is there any comment on that
is the board happy for the people i've
mentioned to be involved
uh does anybody else wish to um throw
their hat into the ring
and be a part of these working groups
chair uh to ask the the leisure one who
was the
um who's the board member for the uh
leisure one
the charlie park project so thank you
the link between the um the charlie
park leisure center and the town
investment plan would be lee hicken
is not a board member though
very true so um yeah he's he's the link
but obviously if there's a board sponsor
as well if somebody willing to to come
forward for that that would be
helpful um well it's uh it's
my portfolio at council so i'd be happy
to do that
okay so there's an existing shy park
leisure center group so
um i would sort of speak with matt and
lead this sort of
make sure you're sort of fitting with
that and you're aware of the existing
processes and then uh
no way you can feedback thank you
are we all happy for that for the rest
of the group
chair could i um just ask that um
the composition of those groups and
attendees from different organizations
is confirmed as well
yeah thank you
yeah what we'll do is we'll we'll pull
together we've we've started to some of
the groups are existing
so we can pull them together and those
groups are in development we will
make sure they're identified and we can
circulate it to
the board and then if you if you see
anybody that should be on there and
there's been
missed solid bags and i'm sure um but
you can make sure they're put forward
and if there's any other
organizations that you feel should be
represented on there
then you can let us know so we'll do
that piece of work make sure it's clear
which
it's known who is the chair who is the
sponsor and who's just a participant
thank you
okay moving on to the next point which
is next step so again straight back to
call
okay um so the next steps is um we've
got a tan investment plan
to discuss when the meeting is no longer
live
um it's been circulated to the group
already um hopefully you've had a chance
to read it what i
would ask for you to do is for all
comments to return to me by
tuesday next week we've had a check-in
challenge session
with the town hub which has been really
helpful
actually that was that was held
yesterday and they talked us through
some
stuff some of these bits that they they
really liked some bits where we could
um presentationally improve it i think
we've also had um feedback from melanie
as well
in terms of experience she's learned
from cohort one and
and also some other bits because mel and
her
colleagues will be the ones scoring it
so it's about making it as easy as
possible
for them to read and score and so
the the at this point we're over the
word limit which obviously we're aware
of
but there are things that we can do to
sort of bring down that word limit so
where does any sort of
hint of duplication and we can take that
out but also where there's
and the opportunity to use infographics
which will obviously lift
um the the report in itself but also
will
reduce the word count because as you
know you know picture paints a thousand
words so there's
there are opportunities to um to get the
message across in a slightly simpler and
easier way
um so if i can have all comments back by
tuesday
next week to me and appreciate that's
only a few days away but the the report
was circulated earlier in week so
hopefully you've had a chance to eat it
already
and then i'll share those with with
nexus i'll sort of try and collate them
and group them thematically and so that
makes it easier for nexus 2 and to deal
with it in one hit rather than going
direct to nexus because then they could
end up with 50 emails where it could be
easier just just to have the one
so that's that's the ask really and and
then
once the work's been done nexus i wasn't
going to propose that we have another
board meeting and
a formal board meeting as such as this
because of the time scales in terms of
getting the papers
in would mean that probably nexus had
got probably a week
to uh work on that um piece of um
feedback from from everybody and i get
it designed up
so the um the hope is that we will get
the feedback on tuesday
share that with nexus they all build
that into the work
the plan will take on board the work the
feedback we've had already
and then we'll get that designed up and
in a position that we can circulate it
via email to this group
and then that can then be um agreed
electronically but just gives that
um it gives nexus a little bit longer
to make sure the time investment plan is
right and
um they're not having to rush it to for
a board meeting
um time scales so appreciate
doing electronically it's not ideal but
because we're getting that close now to
the
the final time scale of the 30th of
october
um and the timescales of having to
publish papers we need to give
nexus as long as possible so is um
is everybody comfortable with that
approach so timescales is tuesday
for feedback to me i'll get it to nexus
and then nexus we'll pull it together
and as soon as we've got the final draft
we'll get that circulated via email
we have a few days to read it
uh depending on obviously when it comes
in and hope to give you as long as
possible to
to read it in advance of the 30th of
deadline and then all comments back to
me
and then hopefully we'll get it
submitted
if we can have some nods of heads or
fingers up or
whatever if you guys can put your
cameras on just so we can have a show of
hands on that
make sure we have agreements
okay thank you it that feels like the
effort is sort of on board with that
approach
and obviously there's no idea but the
deadline is approaching quickly so i
don't think we could do it in any other
way really thank you thank you so if you
can now
unusually go to any other business which
won't be the last point
for this meeting so any of the business
from the board members
if no additional topic store is then we
can move to
the drafttime investment plan
submissions
and i think we need to switch off the
live feed at this point due to the
commercial sensitivity of the topic
you